this is a production of Cornell
University
my lab works on DNA methylation and
epigenetic inheritance and well I'll
tell you about today is a problem we've
been working on for a few years which is
how do a plant and other eukaryotes
actually manage to inherit patterns of
DNA methylation on chromatin so how does
efficient inheritance work around this
the structure where DNA is ramped around
around histones so I'll start the talk
by introducing DNA methylation and
epigenetic inheritance and then I'll
tell you about our work in the trying to
understand how this deals with with
comment in and then I'll finish up with
with some evolutionary implications of
for our work so first just to introduce
epigenetic inheritance and and how DNA
methylation plays around us so this is
nicely illustrated by the synopsis gene
called FWA and this gene is normally
silenced in in Arabidopsis plants in
vegetative tissues and it's silenced by
DNA methylation that is present on the
promoter and the start of transcription
of this gene and now about 25 years ago
Martin Clunes lab isolated a semi
dominant late flowering mutants that
they called FWA and when they tried to
figure out what was causing this they
found this gene that was over expressed
in in in the leaves of these mutants but
there were no genetic differences
between this FWA and this sub waa and
the reason for the phenotype is that
this FWA version is not methylated so
these plants are genetically identical
they don't
don't have any and a DNA sequence
differences the only difference is that
here the stain is methylated and here is
not methylated and these two methyl
states are these two states very stable
in the laboratory at least these plants
will always be early flowering and this
genes always be methylated in silence
this genes will be always late flowering
and this gene will always be a
methylated AM and active and in fact
they're stable enough that you can cross
them together so you can put and cross
these plans with these plants and these
methylated are methylated alleles will
stay methylated and are methylated than
they have to they'll segregate as
Mendelian illegals and so this behaves
as a perfectly normal Mendelian Indian
trade and this isn't just a property
that occurs in the laboratory so we
round the same time Rikka corn slab of
described a epigenetic allele in
toadflax the toad facts normally has
bilaterally symmetric flowers but a wild
normally occurring version of these
species has these so-called polar
explorers which have radial symmetry and
very different arrangements of the
flowers and this is caused by
methylation and silencing of the cyclo
dia transcription factor and this allele
justice was actually described as far
singer for the first time by Linnaeus in
1753 old illegal and it's been around
for at least 150 years in natural
populations of toadflax so these
methylated and unmethylated states
candidates should be quite quite stable
and persistent
but this this ability of DNA methylation
to do carry epigenetic information has
to do with how it's initiated and
maintain them what I'll tell you today
is fairly specific for for plants but it
works in a similar way in animals too so
in this is the the really the plant
specific part where in plants DNA
methylation is initiated by this pathway
called RNA directed DNA methylation
which is a derivative of RNA
interference this is very simplified
very very simplified version of how this
works so a transcript is made that is
recognized as aberrant in some way
perhaps is double-stranded have there
there are other issues with this and
then it is converted upon conscription
and this transcription occurs by pol ii
but it also occurs by a plant specific
version of polymerase to go pol for and
it's converted by an RNA dependent RNA
polymerase called our tier 2 into double
stranded version that is then processed
by a Dicer nucleus into small rnas the
smaller is get loaded into a effective
complex that contains an organelle
protein and this appears to interact
with a nascent RNA made by another
derivative of pol ii called pol v
that has an accessory nucleosome
remodeling protein called dirty one and
we'll talk about remodeling proteins
more than a second and this interaction
somehow activates a DNA
methyltransferase which in Arabidopsis
is called drm to that methylates the DNA
and it suppresses transcription from
from the slogans
now the DRM methyltransferases and their
animal homologs called e93
they can't fix of some extent methylated
cytosines in any sequence context so all
the methylation I'll talk about today is
methylation of cytosine sin the sister
the the predominant form of DNA
methylation in in eukaryotes but if in
plants if the RNA signals turned off
then this methylation would disappear
because the after DNA replication the
old strand here in black keeps its
methylation but the new strand in red is
synthesized unmethylated there's another
methyl transferase system that is there
to keep the methylation propagated
across generations and this is a methyl
transfer is called met wan in plants and
dnmt1 in in animals and what it does is
with at least one accessory protein it
recognizes cg the nucleotides that are
methylated in one strand but not on the
other and then it methylates the
unmethylated cytosine and because these
sites are symmetrical this catalysis
essentially allows semiconservative
inheritance of DNA methylation patterns
everytime the DNA is replicated and this
this is the core catalytic process that
as far as we know makes DNA methylation
epigenetic so this allows for the
methylation patterns to go through
mitosis and at least some plans to go
through meiosis very effective
so in implants there's another yet
another pathway for DNA methylation that
I need to introduce so the
I'll go on I think I hope I didn't make
a mistake I might have copper copied
their own version of my talk into this
computer we'll see if if I did we might
have need to do a little switch so yes
sir because a third of the talk this
slide was meant to come first so I'll
just go back right so for so if I just
first want to tell you about the
function of DNA methylation in implants
and the major function appears to be the
silenced trance possible elements so the
basic idea is the transposons will be
methylated and this methylation will be
heritable in her to be maintained and it
will silence these transposons and this
will preserve the integrity of the
genome and then gene regulation of kinda
showed you will FWA will happen when a
transposon will insert in the vicinity
of a gene and this will become
methylated and then this has the
potential to silence the gene so there's
also a type of DNA methylation in in
plants and many animals which is present
with inactive genes but we won't really
talk about that today the entire talk
will be focused on transposon
methylation and in plants particularly
in transposons there's another DNA
methylation system so in addition to the
93 MD 91 their chroma methylases and
these are methyl transferases and the
one that are in their evidence is called
CMT 3 and that methylates a context
called c h g so it's called those
because H stands for anything but gene
and it's just down to two separate this
context from the one catalyzed by map
one and these these methyl transferases
are
linked to a histone modification called
HT k 9m e 2 which is the die methylation
of lysine 9 of histone h3 into all kinds
of DNA methylation all these three
pathways convergent transposons and
because these DRMs are not very sequence
specific their methylation is generally
referred to CH h see anything but G
anything but G so separated from the
kinds catalyzed I'm at one the kind is
catalyzed by CMT 3 I'm apologize for the
full of slides mix-up so the one thing I
wanted one final thing I wanted to
mention is that fro it's well known and
plans for quite a few years stuff pretty
much all the cg methylation is catalyzed
by this enzyme at one and all the CH d
methylation is catalyzed by this enzyme
CMT 3 but the not all the CH h
methylation is catalyzed by the drm so
there was something else missing from
from this picture that was mediating
some of this asymmetric CH h methylation
okay
so now that I've introduced DNA
methylation and epigenetic inheritance
kind of get to the heart of the talk
which is how this actually works within
chromatin
all right so everything I showed you so
far is methyl transferases methylating
DNA but this DNA is wrapped around
around the nucleus ohm and the this
imposes certain limitations on DNA
methylation and these limitations I
think became kind of clear quite a while
ago when Eric Richards discovered this
gene called em1 and the game long came
out of a genetic screen for mittens with
large losses of DNA methylation and
didn't want turned out to be a type of
protein called a nucleus or remodeler
that is basically a ATPase driven ATP
driven machine that does work on
nucleosomes so these are proteins that
can assemble nuclear films they can move
nucleosomes they can space out nuclear
films they can disassemble nucleosomes
they can take out a part of when you
could assume and put another party yeah
so they're kind of these work engines
that that's worked with chromatin and so
the identification of this gene made it
clear that the the nucleosomes and
chromatin had an important influence on
DNA methylation and later people figured
out the DNA dm1 loss of function causes
major methylation losses in all sequence
contacts so it affects CGC HD and
situation methylation it is required for
methylation in transposons but not in
genes so this gene methylation I
mentioned is not affected really by TM
one
it has a close homolog and mount mammals
called LSH that appears do more less the
same thing but how did he mom actually
interfaced with DNA methyltransferase
systems including RNA directed intimate
relations really unclear how it actually
was mediating methylation and all all
the different sequence contacts so
initially we approach this by analyzing
DNA methylation genome-wide in DMR
mutants and and Wheaton's that affected
this our lead directly DNA methylation
and the two meetings we worked with the
most as our dr to this mutant in this
RNA dependent RNA polymerase in dr d1
this nucleus m remodeler which is
specifically seems to be required for
RNA directed DNA methylation so it's a
protein district homologous to DM 1 and
i will be showing you quite a lot of
these these plots these are meta
analyses that show an averaging of all
the DNA methylation of a particular kind
of sequence this guy this case
transposon so I'll always be showing in
transposon and transposons are aligned
at the 5 prime end in the 3 prime end
and then the methylation across all
transposons averaged in both directions
so we're getting an average amount of
DNA methylation for cg e CH d and c HH
mm-hmm in wild i've been read
methylation is how for cg mutating our
DDM doesn't have much of an effect on
this d DM 1 has a very strong effect on
cg methylation and double meetings
between d DM 1 and RNA dependent RNA
polymerase sorry or this dr d 1 so
double mutants in d DM 1 and are neither
after DNA methylation are a little bit
stronger but just just a little bit but
there's really very little methylation
left in d DM one already for CHD
methylation the situation is a bit in
between
the our DDM mittens have a bit of a
stronger effect the game one has
intermediate level so methylation and
the double mutants have very low levels
and force ehh it's even more dramatic
where our DDM meetings or DD m1 have
these intermediate effects and almost
all the population is gone and in one
our DDM doubles so kind of the bottom
line here is that DTM on an hourly
direct DNA methylation our complimentary
methylation systems and if you get rid
of both of them you basically get rid of
almost all the transposon methylation
and ever the abscess genome and so the
next thing which we try to do is to link
link the this phenomenon to the metal
transferases that we're doing it and so
the first two two parts here are just
what we already knew for cg methylation
if we mediate met one there's almost
nothing well for CHD methylation if we
meet with a 73 there's almost nothing
left and a homologous mp3 called cmp 2
has a very small effect on this kind of
methylation but when we look at CH h
methylation we find that in drm to
eden's so these are the this is the
methyl transferase link to our DDM we
have a a partial loss of methylation
which looks exactly the same as the loss
of methylation in our DDM meetings but
in the CMT to methyl transferase there's
chroma methylase that is homologous to
see mp3 there's a very strong loss of
methylation and between these two they
account for all the non SI g methylation
all the CH h methylation in in the
genome so cmgc if you do was this
missing missing missing bits that was
responsible for 14 em inflation and
however the opposite and I think you
probably are noticing that the shapes of
these lines are different and they the
meetings that belong to the same pathway
resemble each other said so our DDM
meetings have this kind of bell-shaped
shape and DDM one meetings or CMT two
meetings they have this smiley face
shape and this is actually quite
informative about what what they're
doing this is just a zoom in on the CH h
methylation plants so what we're doing
here is we're lighting transpose ons
from either edges and then we're going
into the middle so close to the points
of alignment the methylation average is
is a small transpose ounce or the edges
of longer transpose if we move in
further and further in we're getting
methylation from bigger and bigger
elements right so by the time we're in
here it's 4k via 4k bien
all right so only large elements will be
averaged here and so these these
different shapes actually tell you about
the kinds of transposons that are being
methylated so in our DDM mutants it's
the smaller transposons that are here
the edges that are losing methylation
and then CMT two and in DDM one it's
mostly the larger transposons are here
here in the middle and this is a more
formal analysis of this where here we
are averaging methylation with respect
to the size of off transposons and in
while table there's not much of a
relationship
mm-hmm but in DM 1 and in CMT to the
bigger transpose on the bigger gloss of
DNA methylation
and for our DM for DRM - or for DRD one
the big religions falls on the smaller
gloss in the DNA methylation different
sizes of transportable elements are
relying more on different systems our
DDM is more for for smaller elements and
DM 1 and C 2 for this kind of
methylation are more for larger element
which which is interesting but it's not
terribly satisfying why why how why does
the transposon size matter and actually
what matters isn't the size it met what
matters is the type of chromatin these
transposons
it just so happens the smaller
transposons in there Abba dabbas are
morally chromatic and bigger transposon
some more heterochromatic and that's
actually what makes the difference so
this I'll show you that that that just
just in the bid this is just - we have
to help you visualize what's what's
going on is a particular example so this
would be a short transpose and in there
of analysis will be a long one
and the system escalation in wild type
and for the short runs falls on in gr d1
and DRAM on the inflation is gone but in
DD m1 the CMT - is still there for the
long turns ball down in gr d1 and DRM to
the methylation is mostly there except
right great at the edges of the
transpose and for DD m 1 and CP 2 it's
the opposite is the methylation at the
edges that are still there but the the
middle is is gone and in the double
meetings all the methylation basically
Scott
and this these remnants of methylation
here correlate with the smaller names so
this deer this pathway is driven by
small RNAs and so in the absence of DDM
one and TMP to the little bits of
remaining methylation are catalyzed by
our DDM through the smaller renée's so
this is now an analysis that looks
explicitly at this question of of
chromatin and so for this we're
confining ourselves for smaller
transposon transposons which are lower
smaller than 500 base pairs so that size
variation is not not an issue and we're
just here calculating correlation
coefficients so each of these bar bar
shows the correlation coefficient
between the loss of DNA methylation in
DDM one in three different sequence
contacts c GH d CH h associated with a
particular feature of chromatin and what
this shows is that nucleus own densities
and histone modifications associated
with heterochromatin like h TK 9 and die
methylation are positively correlated
with loss of methylation in DDM
armenians and histone modifications
associated with euchromatin are
negatively correlated so a digimon is
much more required for heterochromatic
transposons and it's much less required
from a euchromatic
and the same thing in Reverse is true
for methylation guided by smaller names
this is the same kind of analysis for
methylation that depends on didi Wong
it's the component of our DDA I mean
here nucleus um density and
heterochromatin are negatively
correlated and euchromatin is positively
correlated so our DM doesn't work very
well in heterochromatin it works much
better in euchromatic but there's one
feature here really which isn't
heterochromatin or euchromatin it's
nucleus cells so nuclear some density
correlates negatively with with our DDM
and positively with with the game one
and we'll get back to that a little bit
later in the talk but basically for now
heterochromatin DDM while and
euchromatin
our DDM this is just a model summarizing
this this part of the talk where we have
a typical long heterochromatic transpose
on and and then short euchromatic
transpose on and their methylated
differently the euchromatic transpose of
lis methylated by this our DDM system
and the CH h methylation will be mostly
guided by DRMs where's the
heterochromatin requires dd m14 for DNA
methylation and this somehow allows
methylation by met one and 73 and 72 of
this of the strands possible
so this links the amount of
heterochromatin but it doesn't really
explain what it is about her chromatin
that makes DTM one important why is it
the BDD one heterochromatin more than
you Crump and this is where I work with
DD m1 intersected with our work with
another component of chromatin linker
histone h1 so h1 is a a very abundant
protein that's found in most eukaryotes
including in in plants and in animals
and this is a highly schematic picture
of this so this is a nucleus services
DNA coming coming in and out of the
nucleus own h1 binds to the DNA between
nucleosomes the so called linker DNA
that's why it's called linker histone
and it also binds though to the nucleus
zone and this this dual interaction with
the linker gained in the new and the
nucleus arm is hypothesized to kind of
be be a vice that stabilizes the nucleus
arm and so h1 is associated with
heterochromatin is associated with
inaccessible chromatin it can impede
nucleus and remodelling and we were
became interested in h1 because it's
been reported to cause interesting and
strange effects on DNA methylation in
various species so h1 mutations in the
fungus called thus Kabbalists were shown
to took the cause overall increase in
DNA methylation basically across the
genome methylation would increase in
mice a schwa mutations are published to
have a localized losses of DNA
methylation so certain particular
regions of the genome would lose DNA
methylation and their absence
study suggested that there were sort of
random effects in DNA methylation H
wrong mutations would cost increases and
decreases more or less randomly strategy
so very curious about this and the first
thing we actually did is the map h1
across the genome just to see where it
goes and not surprisingly it goes to
heterochromatin so there are two h1
genes in the rabbit OPS's h 1.1 which
one or two and this is these are chip
chip seek data where both of them
localized to around the centromere and
this is where heterochromatin is is
where most transposons in their ever
lives is live it's this protein is
highly enriched in heterochromatin and
we already sort of knew this from
psychology down many years ago and this
is a enrichment of h1 in transpose ions
because transposons live in
heterochromatin if something is
originally heterochromatin it will
generally be found in transposons
so both versions of each one are highly
enriched in transposons but there are
specifically duration heterochromatic
transpose so if we separate based on
histone modifications transposons is a
heterochromatic and euchromatic
then heterochromatic transposons are
highly enriched for h1 and euchromatic
transposon for not enriched at all so h1
is is an Arab lobsters heterochromatic
protein it's not only in heterochromatin
sexually found in genes too but it's
highly enriched in heterochromatic
control and in look we look at DNA
methylation we saw something was quite
interesting that h1 had kind of a dual
effect on DNA methylation it's most
obvious effect across the genome was an
increase so in all three sequence
contact CG ch3 and CH h h1 meetin's had
more methylation and transposons than
wild
and this was particularly dramatic at CH
demethylation but it was in all three
contacts but the shape of this
methylation was different right so it's
not this curve was a lot steeper here
that's a wild type and for thh
methylation you can actually see it it
intersects and it basically means that
shorter more chromatic elements actually
losing methylation and longer more
heterochromatic elements are getting in
and this is a more formal analysis of
this where we are dividing transposons
into heterochromatic and euchromatic
types and then we're comparing
methylation between h1 and wild-type and
plotting the overall distribution of the
differences between the h1 meetings in
the wild time so these these curves here
represent the distribution of the
methylation differences and so if the
curve is shifted to the right of of the
started line it means it's more
methylated than h1 the curve is shifted
to the left it means that these
sequences are less methylated in h1
mutants so for all three sequence
contacts heterochromatic transposons are
hyper methylated in h1 meetings and
there are methyl hyper methylated pretty
evenly so these these these brownish
curves have a nice Gaussian shape you
chromatic elements shown in red lose DNA
methylation in in h1 and it was a bit
less evenly especially for CG
methylation there's this long tail and
so there are some sequences which have
very strong loss of cg methylation in
each one minutes so I think this helps
to reconcile some of the conflicting DNA
methylation data that have been
published about h1 so it does have two
effects it causes loss of methylation
and gains but in different sequences
because increases in heterochromatin and
losses in new crop
and this this generalized increase of
DNA methylation heracross in
heterochromatin looked a lot to us like
the opposite of what happens in DTM one
means DDM one we conceived a generalized
loss of DNA methylation heterochromatin
and here we have a generalized gain so
the curious what will happen if we
actually put these put these mutants
together and what happens is that in the
absence of h1 the DDM one phenotype is
is greatly greatly relieved so these are
distinct kinds of parts shown for h1 now
in green wild-type in in red
DVM one in blue and two replicates of
compound meetings between h1 DDM one in
brown and in all sequence contacts the
amount of DNA methylation in these h1
DDM one compound meetings are much
higher than so and this is particularly
dramatic to see th methylation where
here basically the compound mutants look
like h1
and this is just just examples of what
this looks like has heterochromatic
elements where wild-type isn't red
h1 is in green I think you can kind of
see if you look closely enough in this
element this effect where methylation is
increased in h1 but this very Jaggi kind
of outline turns out very smooth and in
em1 these transposons lose methylation
as pretty much all of them do and in the
compound meetings this this loss of
methylation is largely reversed
and if we examine what happens in these
compound beatings carefully was actually
fine is that this methylation dichotomy
between euchromatic and heterochromatic
transposons that exists in Digimon
beatings disappears
now heterochromatic and euchromatic
transposons are behaving more or less
the same with respect to methylation
laws and EDM 1 so I'll walk you through
this analysis these parts each of these
lines represents the ratio of
methylation between a mutant and wild
type so h1 is a ratio of H 1 to
wild-type this blue line is the h1 DDM
one compound meetings versus wild type
and the black is DD in one meeting
versus wild for the 3 sequence count
so for DM 1 it it shows the
characteristic d DM 1 phenotype where
I'm sorry and then we are arranging them
with respect to heterochromatin so the
most euchromatic transposons are here
the most heterochromatic transposons are
here this is counted as the amount of
this histone modification so transposons
are ranged from euchromatic to
heterochromatic and as we get from more
heterochromatic to more heterochromatic
transposon the DNA methylation drops
indeed em1 means in all 3 sequence
contacts
and in h1 these red lines due to the
opposite so there's a bit of loss in
euchromatic elements and a bit of gain
in heterochromatic elements this is a
curse and see and this occurs in see a
change and when we look at h1 DDM Wong
we find is something that looks very
much like h1 there's a relatively
relatively flat relationship for cg
there's same kind of shape here
as for h1 for CH D and almost identical
methylation in CH h and so if we
actually take h1 out of the equation if
we just superimpose these these patterns
so which are 3 th one is the background
and compare H 1 to H 1 DM 1 then we get
relatively flat lines for both of them
for all the contacts so what this is
saying is that when H 1 is gone then you
chromatic transpose downs and
heterochromatic transpose on sluicey and
immolations about the same extent it
became on mutants and so the now the
more the more detailed model is that at
least a major thing that makes
heterochromatin required the game one is
H 1 that it's the presence of H wand and
heterochromatin that really really
requires the new one activity to allow
these methyl transferases to their jobs
but this model though still doesn't
explain what it is the DDM one does
exactly now what kind of activity does
it perform that along with methyl
transferases to do their jobs and how
does it actually interact with each one
does it remove each one is that what it
does and if that's what it does why do
actual meetings have only a partial
rescue of the D Game one phenotype so we
need a number of things to address this
and one of them is to examine the
relationship between D DM 1 and H 1 D DM
1 and Method DNA methylation and
nucleosomes this digimon of the nucleus
M remodeler and supposed to work on
nucleosomes so before I get get to the
data I just want to conceptually you
know explain what we are up against in
complex genomes like Kirby Dobbs's or or
humans for our mouths nucleosomes are
not arranged the same way or across the
genome and they're not they're not
arranged with equal reliability either
so there's some places in the genome
where nucleosomes are positioned
reliably which means that if you look at
chromosome one chromosome another
chromosome a third chromosome 10,000
chromosomes the nucleosomes are going to
be all pretty much in the same place and
when you average them together with
whatever analysis you're doing they're
going to get a nice representation of
the nucleus emplacement but in other
parts of the genome there are equally
some sort of positioned poorly we so in
one chromosome equation will be this
position and another chromosome Illume
in this position another chromosome will
be in this position this doesn't mean
these nucleus oops are not stable it's
just that every time chromatin is
assembled after cell division the
nucleation will occupy outright a
different place
and when you average all of this you get
out something like that right you don't
really get much useful information out
of this so if you're trying to
understand how something like DNA
methylation relates to nucleus ohms the
first the first order of business is to
find places that look like this because
there are the one there is where you can
learn something places look like this
basically scramble all the information
about about where nucleosomes is really
certain each individual piece of DNA so
with this in mind I'm going to skip a
lot of analysis and kind of just get to
the point so this is a heat map where
the redder the color the higher the
feature and so this is a heat map of
nucleosomes in h1 DD in one meetings
each line is a different piece of DNA
and this is centered on a well
positioned nucleus on it so these
represent these reliably positioned
areas of the genome these are places in
the genome where nucleus arms sit in in
more or less the same places in all the
cells and I'm going to look at DNA
methylation there what you get is
something that looks
similarly equally well well arranged so
this is now CG methylation these h1 edmo
means I mean so rad will be more
methylation blue will be less the
methylation is in well well-defined
stripes that are in between the nucleus
and this is a a just a averaging of this
this type of data compressed into a
single into a into a single single
averaged graph so the gray are the
nucleosomes so this this would be this
bright nucleus on here
the and the solid lines are DNA
methylation in the cg context the the
blue is h1 black is wild-type brown is
h1 DTM one and orange is DDM one so this
this brown line just represents the
average of this data where DNA
methylation is now highly periodic and
it oscillates between very low levels of
DNA methylation in the nucleus on cores
where DNA is wrapped around the histones
and nearly wild-type levels of
methylation in the linker DNA between
equals and you can see the same thing in
the match to the much smaller extent
indeed em1 meetings where the
there's more methylation remaining in
the space between nucleus films and
there's essentially no methylation where
nuclear some sets see the same thing for
the other kinds of DNA methylation this
is for CH G and now you can see that
this oscillation actually exists in all
genotypes including in wild-type
there's a preference for for meekley
some linkers but it's much much more
dramatic in NH 1d dm1 and it's the same
for CH h I didn't put h1 and wild I've
here because the lines intersect it'll
be much much too confusing but it's it
basically looks similar to this where
you have this periodicity that is very
very prominent in h1 Digimon double
mutants but not in DD m1 okay good so I
remember I told you that DM 1 actually
has a mammalian homologue called LS h
and so we wanted to see if we could we
could basically see the same kind of
phenomenon going on in LS h meetings and
there's DNA methylation data are
available for LS h mutant Mouse cells so
this is a graph what we're doing is we
are aligning sequences centered on the
binding sites of a protein called CT CL
ctcf is a is a mammalian protein that is
well known to orient people systems
around this so it kind of forms
well-positioned to do some surveys
around it and it also depletes DNA
methylation where it binds so the grey
line here are nucleosomes in in Mouse
cells around cdcf sites and they show
some periodicity
and the blue line is wild-type DNA
methylation the right the red line is LS
th mutants DNA methylation in wild-type
there's a little bit of fear this to
here but in LS h there is much more
pronounced for your disappea it looks a
fair bit like the beard esteem DDM one
but this analysis is much much cooler
than what we did here and Arab adopters
and it's actually something that my
postdoc just did yesterday but I so this
needs a lot of work but I just wanted to
show this to you because I think it
shows that this really works more or
less the same probably in plants and
animals and I'll explain what we think
these data means using this model so at
least a large part of how we think this
works is that if we start with with
chromatin the DNA is wrapped in
nucleosomes and in between its
associated with lingo here's an h1 and
then what the Game one does is it it's
that's what inclusive modelers do it
moves or partially disassembles equus
arms or perhaps what it can do is can
make a loop of DNA it comes out of the
nucleus on and for this activity it
makes the DNA accessible to methyl
transferases like Matt Juan because h1
actually doesn't just bind the linker
DNA it also binds to the niqua some
surface it's very hard to imagine how
DTM one can do what it does without also
disrupting contacts with h1 so we think
it just it comes in there - it remodels
nucleosomes it kicks out a Chuang and it
exposes DNA to the DNA methyltransferase
if we don't have h1 in the system then
the linkers are that much more
accessible to DNA methyltransferases
and this we think is a part of the
reason why in h1 meetings
heterochromatin is hypermethylated
because linker DNA is more methylated
considers here we're in each one
meetings when cardina is more methylated
it's actually true for all sequence
context including see Jesus you can't
really see the oscillation very well at
this at the scale when you don't have
dm1 then there isn't a remodeler to
allow the methyltransferases to access
the DNA but the h1 is not as stable as
the nucleosomes let's know that h1 comes
on and off it's a rather relatively
stable protein in its association with
DNA but not nearly as stable as nucleus
and so this this dynamic binding and
binding of h1 allows some access to DNA
methyltransferases indeed em1 movements
and so this agent we think is why you
see some methylation in the linkers for
each one of Digimon meetings but not in
the course and then in the double
mutants in h1 DDM 1 there still isn't a
remodeler 2 to allow access to the
nucleus home of course but the linkers
are relatively available because each
one isn't there and because each one is
concentrated in heterochromatin this
removal of h1 has a much stronger effect
on heterochromatin right you lose h1 and
heterochromatin becomes much more
accessible and you chromatin doesn't
change too much and so then an H 1 D
game one they get this really big
difference in heterochromatin between
between cores and linkers because the
linkers are accessible now without h1
but the cores are still relatively
inaccessible because the game one isn't
there
okay so that's the that's the basic
model where where how well we have it
developed so far it's not quite this
simple but this is this is a first
approximation of how we think h-1b dm1
influenced DNA methylation this is the
finish of the talk I want to go a little
bit into into evolutionary biology
because in my lab this is actually a
substantial interest try to understand
how DNA methylation evolved and we've
with profound DNA methylation in a
number of different species and when we
saw this pattern of methylation this was
a pretty strong strong feeling of deja
vu because we've seen this before and
we've seen this before
in in other species so in our analysis
some of the species that we've looked at
is a particular group of green algae
called the Mamillius
so green algae which is to say plants
are very diverse group of organisms
which embryo fides of which land plants
are part make up just one branch and our
knowledge about these guys in general
and about the DNA methylation
specifically is highly limited so we
have a lot of knowledge about their
epidermis is DNA methylation is present
in these sequence contacts we have some
knowledge about DNA methylation in a
couple of other groups of algae like the
group
welcome to the Morrises and also the
species called but a lot of these other
groups here are a bit of a mystery and
so we will tune this this particular
group which we did partly because it's
it's a very very tiny these are smallest
free-living eukaryotes and were curious
to know what what they were doing with
their DNA methylation and both of these
guys are both of these species that we
looked at have cg methylation
in their genomes and this piece is
actually quite diverse they're about
five hundred million years they works
from each other but the pattern of
methylation was very odd this pattern of
methylation was so these are
representative parts of the genome from
these two species where the methylation
is in blue and the exons are are in
green so these species have methylation
throughout their genome except in
promoters and it's present in this very
regular pattern where there's a short
patch of DNA methylation followed by a
gap in the short patch and a gap on a
short pettish passionate gap and this
this pattern is nucleus all so but by
mapping nucleosomal so they could show
is that the methylation fits between the
nucleosomes so in these species this is
now representative genes methylation
isn't blue nucleosome certain gray and
the methylation fits right between the
nucleosomes
and this is a more sorry this is a more
general analysis where we're aligning at
zero the first methylated base in each
one of these methylated clusters so
we're taking for our starting point the
transition between unmethylated
methylated DNA and averaging methylation
going out 500 base pairs in both
directions or nucleosomes in in gray and
so what this analysis show is that
actually the relationship and DNA
methylation and nucleosomes is very very
strict in these genomes the methylation
is all present between nuclei so that's
basically never present in the nucleus
of the core so these genomes have
everywhere and by default the kind of
methylation pattern that we find in
rabid abscess transposons really mutate
h1 and
together and the thing is this kind of
methylation pattern wasn't just present
in these in these green algae it's
actually present in several very deeply
branching lineages of eukaryotes so this
is a reasonably representative
representative tree of eukaryotic
diversity where the groups that have
this kind of linker specific DNA
methylation are in red and other groups
that have DNA methylation everywhere are
in green and what was very puzzling
about this was that this linker specific
pattern of methylation was interspersed
with species which didn't have it it
wasn't confined to one particular part
of the training so this group of green
algae I just told you about helps us
better in the methylation but other
green algae don't and land plants don't
help divides have a very very similar
pattern DNA methylation to these guys
there however are very distantly related
to other eukaryotes it's hard hard to to
to make much of these but instrument
vials brown algae have a pattern
basically indistinguishable from these
green algae but diatoms the derivatives
have very normal-looking methylation of
transposons that doesn't appear to be
confined to linkage at all at least
based on looking at the whole genome and
none of the animals of plants or fungi
we've looked at has very highly linked
to limited methylation either so we
couldn't really understand how this was
how this was possible but I think I
think our data with h1 and dm1 suggests
an explanation that it's actually not
that difficult the transition between
these two kinds of patterns now we can
convert a rabid abscess at least in part
of its genome from a overall methylation
pattern to a linker specific pattern by
making basically three mutations DDM 1 &
2 H 1 probe
I think it's rather easy to imagine how
small regulatory changes in nucleus of
remodeling can give you a species where
methylation is only in linkers 4 where
methylation is everywhere so I will end
here I'll just thank the people who did
the work the CMT 2 analysis without done
by a graduate student in Hongzhi the
early work on h 1 d DM 1 was done by a
former postdoc of sows emic and a former
graduate student Yvonne Kim the more
recent work on the g1 LS h was from a
current postdoctoral fellow fellow David
Lyons and the evolutionary work I
mentioned at the end was that of a
former postdoc a Jason house this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu